foreign
Florida hi Lisa welcome to the Ramsay
show
well thank you Dave good afternoon how
are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
so my husband and I we have a blended
family he has two children from a
previous marriage and I have four
children from a previous marriage and
three grandchildren
of late uh each of the children for
various reasons and in different
circumstances have gotten themselves
into situation where they need help
which is understandable
The Last of The Brood are 17 year old
twins who will be graduating high school
this year and the oldest would be my 31
year old daughter
and her three children and so we've got
everything in between
um we're trying to figure out where to
draw the line to help them and not
enable them I don't believe that money
is the answer to everything that's just
not how I view Money
and I don't want them to think that
either and we are certainly not
independently wealthy
um we work very hard for what we have so
what was the last request that spurred
this call
foreign
what was the last request from a kid
that spurred this call
well
um my second oldest daughter who was 21
got into some trouble at school
and it looks like there's going to need
to be money paid out and my oldest
daughter got into an automobile accident
where the car was totaled and then she
had to admit to me that Not only was she
behind on the car payments but did not
pay the insurance
okay uh your your youngest getting
criminal act are you middle one criminal
activity
uh misdemeanor yep she she got in
trouble and it looks like there may be
some restitution that might be being
requested she's a junior in college
like how much
undetermined I really won't know
anything well ten thousand one thousand
I'm going to say maybe fives okay
uh Lisa my knee jerk is which granted I
have three little ones at home and I'm
realizing
after you experience parenting you have
different opinions on stuff so so Rachel
in 10 years may have a different opinion
Lisa I'm gonna humbly say that so to me
the 21 year old are you still are they
still under you financially your
daughter are you guys paying for school
are you helping her out or is she
completely independent financially
she is not completely independent with
all of my children I've tried to follow
the same protocol as soon as she turned
18 I had the cell phone put into her
name she pays for that I just turned
over the vehicle that I was allowing her
to drive in her name uh within the last
two or three months I put the insurance
in her name and she pays that if she
needs help with her bills she knows that
she can come to me and I'm willing to
help out because I know that school is
becoming more taxing sure but those part
of being an adult you know yeah no
absolutely because for the 21 year old
with with a whole criminal thing and
you're a junior in college all of that
for some reason I have as a parent I
feel the need to to to to step into that
situation
um faster than I would the 31 year old
in the car payment and the insurance
because to me I'm like
why why on both of these is always the
question I want to ask so you know for
the Junior and college so there's
obviously behave there's choices that
are being made in life that are not wise
so there's a big thing there that's not
necessarily a money issue it's become a
money issue because she may have to pay
five thousand dollars or whatever it may
be so you helping pay the financial side
of that while walking with her through
life and saying hey how can I walk
beside you as your mom and love you well
and understand what caused the situation
like that's one thing for me the 31 year
old I'm like okay so then why are you
behind on your car payment why are you
behind on your insurance because that's
an adult Pro like that's a to me like
that's a that's an adult problem like
you you didn't pay something that you're
supposed to be paying and so why is that
is it because you don't have the money
is it because you're not keeping up with
payments and all that so asking that why
question is really big for me Lisa to
understand am I enabling or am I helping
but that 21 year old for some reason my
heart was just like whoo that's not a
money problem yes it's become a money
problem but there's life choices that
are occurring there that I would want to
step into fast the level of help that we
would extend and would be
based on really two things
how repentant are they and repentance
means turning away
so we were walking towards stupid or we
were running towards stupid we not only
stopped but now we're running the other
way that is repentance
I'm never going to do this again I'm
completely changing whatever behavior
that caused this in either of these
cases and I'm running the other way I
just need some help this one time to
turn the corner that is repentance if
that is not there in Spades I mean like
enthusiastic repentance just let them
bathe in it
let them bathe in the pain if that is
there and then you can figure out how
you can on a one-time basis help them
move towards smart from dumb with a
little bit of cash
on a one-time basis then that's good
where we just continually are bailing
them out that's enabling or where you're
bailing out someone who's not repentant
then you want good things for them more
than they do and only Lisa if you guys
have the money you said we're not
financially yeah you don't have the cash
you can't help you can't so you just
sorry stop sorry yeah nope